ก็
สวัสดีค่ะพี่อาร์ตี้นักเรียมาสวยครับนัก
เรียนนเย็นเรียนโหมากกลับมาเรียนภาษาไทย
กับเกียร์ตีและตี้เรียมเรียงในช่องช่อง
อะไรเอ่ยคอมเพลนสิเบิ้ล Thailand  Store
ไทยนะครับโอเควันนี้วันที่เรามาเรียนภาษา
ไทยกันวันนี้วันนี้วันอะไรครับ
วันนี้ใช่แล้ววัน
วันอังคารวันนี้เปรี้ยว
จำวัน
พุธวันนี้ค่อยนะคะอาหารไงเอาหรอ
ใช่ไหมใช่วันนี่
มีวันอังคารวันอังคารพี่
วันอังคารที่เท่าไหร่ก็วันนี้ 18 เอ้อใช่
มั้ยโอเควันอังคารที่ 18 แล้วโอเควัน
อังคารที่ 18 แล้วเรียนอะไรครับเดือนนี้
เดือนมกราคมค่ะเดือนมกราคมนะโอเคให้แล้ว
เปลี่ยนติเพียรติดได้ยินบางคนบางคนบางคน
พูดเดือน
มกราคม
ใช่ค่ะเดือนมกราคมหรือมกราคมเหมือนกัน
เหมือนกันได้ๆโอเคเดือนนี้เดือนมกราคมนะ
โอเค
มกราคมกราคมแค่แล้วปีนี้ปีพศอะไรครับ
ข้อ 2 ต.ค
2012  5
2022 โอเคครับแล้วปีพศอะไรครับข้อสอบ
ต2561
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
ตินปาตีนทินผิดฝ่าเท้า
555 หน้า
แล้วฮะปีนี้ปีปีพ.ศ
2522 นะครับปีนี้ให้ค่ะมิ
2022 แล้วปีที่แล้วปีที่แล้วปีอะไรครับ
E ที่แล้วปี
2021 อ่าปีที่แล้ว 2,000 บาท 21 นะครับ
แล้วปีหน้านะครับปีหน้าปีหน้าปี
2010  23  5
2013 ได้ครับปีหน้าปีหน้าน่าตบ 5 ปีนี้
ก่อนมาพี่เออันนี้นักปีนี้ปีนี้ตอนนี้
ครับตอนนี้ตอนนี้กี่โมงแล้วครับ
ตอนนี้
09:15 น 5  9:00 น
10 น
[เพลง]
ก็
ใช้คนไปคนไทยเรียก 21:00 น 21:00 นๆ 5
โอเคเป็นพระอาทิตย์ตกแล้ว
คนไทยก็จะพูดเลข 7 เป็นหนึ่งอ้ะได้ครับ
ตรงนี้เราจะเรียก
1-1  7:00 น 7:00 นได้ครับตรงนี้
8:00 นหน้าตรงนี้ก็เลยก็เลยก็เลยได้ยิน
น้องเรียมพูดว่าถาม 19:00 นใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะ
อีกเข้าเป็น 4 เป็นถ้าเป็น 6 ส้ายอ่ะ
สำหรับคนไทยนะคนขายอาจได้ครับอาตอนนั้น
ตอนนี้
21:00 น
21:00 นติดใช่นาทีนี้ก็
เพราะว่าเขาได้ยินเสียงตีกลองหรือเปล่าคะ
เฮียตีที่มันดังตุ่มอ๋อ
ก็ไปที่เลข 7 ห้องได้ยินใช่ไหมคะ
ใช่ครับแต่กลางวันก็ได้ยิน
บางวันก็ตีแต่เป็นเสียง mon  mon เข้า
เหรอใช่ค่ะตอนเจ็ดโมงเช้าเขาก็เรียกว่า
1โมงไงอ๋ออ่อนขึ้นหมอ
เขาเสียงงงงง
คอ
ที่เป็นเสียงกลางวันเป็นเสียงระฆังใช่ไหม
รางวัล
เป็นเสียงระฆัง
1 จำไม่ได้
ใช่ไหม
กลางวันเป็นเสียงรักค่าหวย
หุ้นวัน
เสียงระฆังเสียงดัง mon  mon  mon ใช่
มั้ยก็เรียก 2 โมง 15:00 น 16:00 นอย่าง
นี้หรอแล้วตอนกลางคืน
กลางคืนเป็นเศียรกอง
อ้าเป็นเสียงกลอง
หาเวลาตีเวลาตีกองก็ใช้ไม้ใช้ไม้ตีถ้ามี
เสียงทุ่มตุ้มตุ้มตุ้มตุ้มแบบนี้ออกข้อ
เรียก 1 ทุ่ม 2 ทุ่ม 3 ทุ่มน้อ
โอเคโอเคนี้เป็นตอนบางคืนใช่ไหมคืน
555 ขอแค่เธอวันนี้เราเรียนเรื่องอะไร
กันมาคุยหรือ 9:00 น
ไม่เขียว
วันนี้เราจะเรียนเกี่ยวกับเครื่องใช้ไฟ
ฟ้าเครื่อง
และเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้า
ami มีเครื่องอะไรบ้างที่ใช้ไฟฟ้าบ้าง
ครับที่เราจะเรียนกันไฟฟ้าเป็นแบบนี้ใช่
ไหมครับใช่ค่ะใช่ไหมป๊า a ไฟฟ้าโอเคอ่ามี
อะไรบ้างครับที่เราจะเรียนกันมันจะมาคุย
กันว่า
อันไหนคือเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าขอโอเคอันไหนคือ
เครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าโอเคอ่าน้องเรียนมีมีมี
รูปมาให้นักเรียนดูด้วยใช่ไหมครับว้าวมา
แล้วอันไหนใช้
ไฟฟ้าใช่ไหมใช่ค่ะอ่าอันนี้ให้เทียบที่
เหลือเชื่อ 5 พี่ตี้รู้จัก 5 ทั้งสองทั้ง
2 อันนี้ที่เห็นหน้า 2 อันเนี้ยอ่าเรียก
ว่าแปรงสีฟันก็แปลงสีฟันมี 5 ไซส์ค่ะแปรง
สีฟัน
จะมีเบอร์ 1 กับเบอร์ 2  5 เบอร์ 1 กับ
เบอร์ 2 นะครับ
อันไหนเป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าอันไหนใช้ไฟฟ้า
ใช่ไหมครับเพี้ยนตี้คิดว่าเบอร์หนึ่งครับ
เบอร์ 1 ใช้ไฟฟ้า
ขายครับเพราะว่าพี่อาร์ตี้มีแปรงสีฟันแบบ
เบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 2 ที่ปาร์ตี้มีเยอะตีใช้
มันไม่ใช้ไฟฟ้า
ถ้าก็เลยก็เลยคิดคิดว่าเบอร์ 1 ใช้ไฟฟ้า
มือ
เบอร์หนึ่ง
เรียกว่า
แปรงสีฟันไฟฟ้า
ฮะโอเคได้ค่ะเราก็จะใช้มือกดกดปุ่มตรงนี้
อ๋อ
นกแรงก็จะหมู
อ๋ออ๋อมันก็จะหมุน
ใช่ไหมเราก็ไม่ต้องแปลงไม่ต้องแปลงแบบนี้
ไม่ต้องแปลงใช่ไม่ต้องให้
[เพลง]
ศ.โอเค
อ่า
หมุนข้าวเกย์ครับเบอร์หนึ่งก็คือแปรงสี
ฟันไฟฟ้าแปรงสิบพันไปฟ้ามือสองเรียกว่า
อะไรคะพี่บอย 2 เรียกแปรงสีฟันสีฟ้าเขา
ใช่ไหมเค้านักเรียน 1  2 แท่งสีฟันสีฟ้า
จากนั้นแต่ไม่ได้ใช้ไฟฟ้านะไม่ได้ใช้ไฟ
ฟ้าแต่ว่าอาเอาเนาะทั้งเบอร์ 1 กับเบอร์ 2
เตรียมคิดว่าเป็นแปลงสีฟันสีฟ้าเหมือนกัน
โอเคแต่เบอร์ 1 ใช้ไฟฟ้าในครับเบอร์ 2
ไม่ใช้ไฟฟ้า
ชายเพลง I มีรูปต่อไปครับมีรูปอะไรอีก
ครับ
เห็นอะไรอ่ะเพื่อตีเห็นเห็นโคมโคมไฟ
หน้ามิตผมไปอยู่เยอะเลย
อะเดียวเขียนให้เบอร์หนึ่งถามเบอร์ 2
เบอร์ 3
เราก็เบอร์ 4
เบอร์หนึ่งคืออะไรคะพี่อติเบอร์หนึ่งเป็น
โคมไฟ
โคมไฟตั้ง
เต็มโต๊ะ
ชัยข้างอยู่บนตั้งอยู่บนโต๊ะอาโคมไฟตั้ง
โต๊ะใช่ครับอันนี้คือโต๊ะหาใช้ครับมีโต๊ะ
อยู่นี่โคมไฟตั้งบนโต๊ะคนไทยเลยเรียกโคม
ไฟตั้งโต๊ะ
แล้วเบอร์ 2 นะคะอ้าเบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 2 ก็
โคมไฟโคมไฟเหมือนกันแต่คอมไฟไม่ได้ตั้ง
อยู่บนโต๊ะแล้วเห็นไหมนักเรียนเห็นไหมคง
ไปไม่ได้ตั้งบนโต๊ะโคมไฟตั้งอยู่ที่ไหน
ครับตั้งอยู่ที่พื้นๆคนไทยเรียบโคมไฟตั้ง
พื้น
ใช่ค่ะ
ซื้อตั้งพื้นนะครับ
แล้วเบอร์ 3 แล้วคะอ้าเบอร์ 3 เบอร์ 3 คน
ไทยเขาเรียกโคมไปแล้วอ่ะคนไทยเรียก
ตะเกียง
ประยังๆครับ
[เพลง]
แล้วเบอร์ 4 หรอคะอ้าเบอร์ 4 เบอร์ 4
เรียบเทียน
เทียนอา
ถูกแล้วเออทุกเบอร์เบอร์มีไฟมีไฟทุกเบอร์
หน้า 8 ไฟไหม้เหมือนกันไม่เหมือนกันแล้ว
แล้วเบอร์ไหนเป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าค่ะอ่า
เบอร์
เบอร์ 1 ใช้ไฟฟ้า
5 เบอร์ 2
เบอร์ 2 ก็ใช้ไฟฟ้าเหมือนกัน
แล้วก็เบอร์ 3
เบอร์ 4 ที่ 3 ไม่ใช้ไฟฟ้า
and ใช้ใช้ไฟไฟไปนี่ครับไฟช็อตน้ำมันชิน
อะไรก็ใช้น้ำมันใช่ครับ
ใช้น้ำมัน
ระเบิด 4 เบิร์ดส Free  Birds  4 ใช้ไฟ
ใช้ไฟแต่ไม่ใช่ไฟฟ้านะครับอันนี้เบอร์ 4
ใช้อ่าเบอร์ 4 เราเรียกว่าเทียน
เทียน
เทียนไข
เทียนไขไม่ใช้น้ำมันใช้ไขมัน
ในเรียกว่าเทียนขายทำมาจากไขมันใช่ครับ
เป็นเทียน
อาหารใช้ครับอาหาร
คำตอบว่า
ขอเบอร์ไหนเป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าอ่าเปียตี
ตอบเบอร์ 1 และเบอร์ 2 ครับเย้เย่ถูกต้อง
ค่ะ
1 และเบอร์ 2 เป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าเคเย้
เก่งมากครับต่อไป
ต่อไป
[เพลง]
อ้าอันนี้หน้าตาหน้าตาเพียงติเห็นหน้าตา
แล้วคุณคุ้นคุ้นคุ้นๆหน้าที่ที่เห็นแล้ว
เห็นแล้วครับ
[เพลง]
คืออะไรค่ะพี่เบ็ตตี้คิดว่านี้เรียกเตา
รีด
เตารีดใช่ครับอ่าเตารีด
เตรียมเขียนเบอร์
1 เบอร์ผมขอเว
เบอร์ 3 ฮะ
แกมีไหนเออใช่ไหม
เบอร์ไหนเป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าอ่าเปียตี้
เกียติรู้จักทั้ง 3 เบอร์พี่ติ๊กเคยใช้
ทุกเบิดแหละๆ
บ้านที่อ่ะที่มีทุกเบอร์เลยโอเคโอเคพี่
รู้จักไว้ในตี้ตอบเลยตอบเลยฮะเบอร์
ไหนใช้ไฟฟ้าหน้าเพชรตี้ตอบว่าเบอร์ 1
เบอร์ 1
และเบอร์
2  2 ใช้ไฟฟ้าครับหูถูกต้องค่ะ
เย้
ต้องแต่ว่าเบอร์หนึ่งเรียกว่า
อ่ะคะหาเบอร์นิ่งของเบิ้ลหนึ่งขึ้นอิ่ม
เรียบเตารีดไฟฟ้า
ใช่ครับเราริไฟฟ้าเบอร์ 2 นะคะ
เบอร์ 2 ก็เป็นเตารีดไฟฟ้าเหมือนกันแต่
แต่เบอร์ 2 ใช้ไฟฟ้าแล้วก็ใช้น้ำด้วยน๊า
เพราะฉะนั้นเบอร์ 2 จะมีไอน้ำออกมา
ไอน้ำ
ตอนนี้คือไอน้ำๆเป็นไอน้ำคนคนไทยก็เลย
เรียกเตารีดไอน้ำ
เตารีดไปมาครับแต่ก็ใช้ไฟฟ้าด้วยใช้ไฟฟ้า
ด้วยแล้วมีไอน้ำออกมาก็มีรักฝ่ายมีสายไฟ
ให้มีสายฟ้าไป
น้า
โอเคแล้วอันที่สามหล่ะคะอันนี้เตรียมก็
เห็นแตกไม่เคยใช้อ๋อโอเค 5 เบอร์ 3 เป็น
เตารีดถ่านนักเรียนเห็นผ่านอยู่ข้างๆไหม
ถ่านชุดทรานว่าไงข้างล่างจะมีถ่านถ่าน
ก้อนสีแดงๆสีแดงๆแล้วก็มีไฟ
หน้ามีไฟเอาถ่านไปใส่เข้าไปในเตารีดไปใน
เตารีดแล้วเต่ารีบก็จะร้อนจะร้อนจะร้อน
ได้ครับแล้วก็เอามารี่ผ้าได้
เครียดที่รีดผ้าด้วยเตารีดที่ 3 เตารีด
ขาดชาย Happy ร้อนมือไหมคะอ่า
นิดหน่อยมิดหน่อยใช่ครับใช่ครับรีดได้เรา
ไม่ได้ใส่ถ่านเยอะใส่ถ่านแค่ให้เตารีดมัน
ร้อนแล้วเราก็รีบได้อ่ะก็ไม่ได้เตรียมคิด
เตรียมคิดว่าไปทานใส่ทานเยอะๆใส่เยอะไม่
ได้ใส่เยอะไม่ได้ได้เยอะฮ่าๆจะไม่
ไม่ไปครับ
อย่าตี้ใช้เตารีดขาดอยู่ไหมคะตอนนี้ไม่
ใช้แล้วครับ
ไปเเลนใช้เป่ารีดอะไรอยู่คะอ่าตอนนี้ใช้
เตารีดเบอร์ 2 ครับเบอร์ 2 เบอร์ 2 ทราย
ใช้เอ็นเตารีดไอน้ำ
[เพลง]
ตอบถูกค่ะ
ออกไป
ตี
5 ต่อไปเห็นอะไรครับว้าวห๊าอะไรเอ่ยพี่
มีเบอร์ 1  5 เบอร์ 1  2 ครับ 5 วันหนึ่ง
3 เบอร์ 3
แคลร์ห้าม
เบอร์หนึ่งคือ 1 คือพัดลม
พัดลมให้ครับพัดลมมาพัดลมใช้ไฟฟ้าเป็น
เครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าเบอร์ 1  5 เพราะว่าเวลา
ที่เราใช้พัดลมเบอร์ 1 เขาต้องเสี่ยง
ปลั๊กด้วยอ๋อมีสอบปลายไฟอีกลักษณ์
ด้วยเหยียบรักให้เป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้า
เรียกว่าพัดลม
แล้วมือสองล่ะคะเบอร์ 2 ใช่ไหมครับ
เบอร์ 2 ก็ใช้ไฟฟ้าเบอร์ 2 เป็นหาคนไทยคน
ไทยเรียกแกอ่ะ
ดูแลใช้ครับห่าแกก็จะมีลมออกมาเหมือนกัน
แต่เป็นลมที่เย็นนมที่ใช้ครับเป็นลมเย็น
มา
ตอนนี้ตอนนี้พี่จะดีก็เปิดเพี้ยนที่เขา
เปิดแอร์ว่าพี่ SC ร้อนร้อนเปิดแอร์เปิด
แอร์ไม่ร้อนแล้วเย็นสบายอ่ะเปิดเปิดแต่นะ
ครับ
ไปนั้นแอร์ใช้ไฟฟ้าใช้ออกใช้ไฟฟ้าแล้วก็
ก็เบอร์ 3 ล่ะคะอ่าเบิร์ดขามันนี้ไม่มี
ไม่มีปลั๊กไม่มีครักษ์หน้าเบอร์ 3 ไม่ใช้
ไฟฟ้า
เบอร์ 3 ครับเรียกว่าอะไรเบอร์ 3 เรียบ
Plus
Cut  Cut ใช้ครับ Pass
สิ่งที่เราใช้เราก็ต้องพลัด
แล้วก็จะมีลมออกมามีลมออกมาเวลาเราพัด
แต่งไม่ใช่ไม่ใช่ผัดลมใช่ไหมคะไม่ใช่พัด
ลมเป็นพัดพัดคำเดียวพัฒน์คำเดียวคัดผัดหา
ถ้าเกิดพัดลมจะเป็นเบอร์หนึ่งชายครับพัด
ลมเป็นเบอร์หนึ่งเราไม่ต้องพลัดเองพัดลม
ทำงานพัดลมหมุนแล้วมีลมเราไม่ต้องพัดเอง
แต่ถ้าพัดเราต้องผัดเอง
โอเค
แบบนี้ก็เรียบค้าใช่ไหมคะได้ครับแบบนี้
เรียบพัดหน้าหน้าแล้วเบอร์ 1 เบอร์ 2
เบอร์ 3 เบอร์ไหนเป็นเรื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าคะอ่า
เปียตี้ตอบว่าเบอร์ 1
และเบอร์
ที่ 2 เป็นเครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าครับน้าเย้ถูก
ต้องค่ะโอเคโอเคว้าววันนี้เราได้เรียนรู้
เครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้าอะไรได้บ้างครับ
วันนี้เราเรียนรู้เครื่องใช้ไฟฟ้ามีแปรง
สีฟันไฟฟ้า
โอเคแล้วก็มีอะไรอีกครับมีคมไฟโคมไฟโอเค
ครับแล้วก็มีเตารีดเตารีดโอเคต้องรีบไฟ
ฟ้าจะไปครับ
พัดลมลมอะสุดท้ายเป็นพัดลมนะครับแล้วก็มี
แอร์ด้วยใช่ไหมอ่ะอ่ะมีแอร์
โอเควันนี้นักเรียนก็ได้รู้จักเครื่องใช้
ไฟฟ้ากันไปแล้วนะครับมีทั้งเครื่องใช้ไฟ
ฟ้าแล้วก็ที่ไม่ใช้ไฟฟ้าด้วยใช่ไหม
ค่ะอ่ะ
ดีแล้วล่ะค่ะใช่ครับเราหมดเวลาแล้วค่ะก็
เสียดาย
50 เสียดายเรียนกับพี่อาร์ตี้กับเราหน้า
กลับมาเรียนกันใหม่ครับผม
ครับวันนี้วันนี้ลาไปก่อนครับผมบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีครับนักเรียนสวัสดีครับน้องเรียม
บ๊ายบายค่ะเทียบอีกสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
หญิงม